le questionner alors le votre mot
préféré sur les manuels ya là ce qui
veut dire en avant de lui ce que j'ai
dit comme ça j'ai dit ah bon dieu
l'amour que vous détestez jamais charité
dans la vie jamais faut toujours courir
charmer et on est toujours toujours vécu
quant aux chats pas de stop votre drogue
oui c'est ça votre favorite de drogue
favorite en ballons là moi je pensais
vous allez me répondre jésus vous voulez
quelque chose de matériel l'anneau nous
vous répondre ce que vous voulez alors
l'astuce l'a6 pour maltais ou jésus il
n'y a rien de commun entre eux oui au
point de vue de quelque chose que j'aime
dans ma bouche c'est l'astuce pour man
tu es beaucoup de champagne très bien si
ce mot là mon coeur ma vie ma force mon
enthousiasme ses juges
c'est juste le son le bruit que vous
aimez c'est le salvé reggina des moines
de lérins
c'est extraordinaire il le chante le
soin après conflit dans leur église tout
et en silence tout est sombre
la vierge est légèrement illuminé et le
chalut oren tu as qu'est notre espoir
c'est vraiment l'humanité du cri était
sûr que finalement battu finira bien
très bien
j'enregistre ça va ça va le son le bruit
que vous détestez alors là j'ai noté le
haut parleur pour un mort pendant le
on parle pour un mot si vous étiez au
caire vous comprendriez oui d'accord
mais sur scène pour entamer sa saison
soit tout à coup ça comment vous êtes
saisis
saül jusqu'à ligne le haut parleur pour
un mort ça vraiment y'a rien alors ma
soeur j'excuse la pose cette question
votre jure au gros mot blasphème je ne
pense pas espèce de charme aux espèces
de chama c'est joli c'est un parce que
le chat vous en afrique est un animal
noble
c'est le plus grand compliment qu'on
puisse faire un homme c'est de lui dire
qu'à match c'est-à-dire chameau un mou
femmes pour illustrer un nouveau billet
de banque
pascal le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire sur un manuel chauffeur poids
lourd pourquoi à ce que j'ai connu des
chauffeurs de poids lourds qui sont
partis dijoux qui sont revenus dans leur
appartement
l'appartement vide la femme partie avec
le gauche jamais oublier ça les dix
chauffeurs de pâles ou c'est un mauvais
mec
bon la plante l'arbre où l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné le
pas lui d'égypte iard ya de plus beau de
plus je ne sais pas
depuis artistique que le palm et
d'egypte qui laisse pour bêcher date
actuelle à obtenait pacha et enfin alors
c'est la question que je vais pas je
fais le tour puis je reviendrai à vous
donc la dernière question évidemment
elle de circonstance comme un vendredi
saint si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire à vous paulo coelho
vous avez combattu le bon combat effet
le bon combat
oui oui du christ hiddink si dieu existe
moi j'aimerais qu'il dise simplement
enfin s'il avait la bonté d'ajouter
c'est la fête alors ce serait parfait
mais champagne que me direz asti
spumante astiz comment alors jean petit
j'aimerais qu'ils me disent vient pour
la fête vient pour le festin vient boire
manger danser tout le monde est invité
ni compris les clandestins noël copains
bien gelé un peu répété les autres mais
j'aimerais qu'ils me disent attend
encore quelques années et je t'offrirai
de l'asti spumante que dû boire avec
soeur emmanuelle
mais pour être plus sérieux puisque pour
moi la foi est un pari pari sur dur sur
l'homme
je pense qu'il me dirais tu vas gagner
ton pari n'est qu'il ajouterait je crois
en l'homme c'est beau alors il vous sera
alors que si dieu existe alors je répète
la question si dieu existe soeur
emmanuelle qui est aussi d'accord il
existe et de dollars qui vous arrive de
doute et ça c'est à l'autre n'ont plus
le temps de pâles
c'est vrai voilà si dieu existe qu
aimeriez vous après votre mort que je
souhaite le plus tard possible vous
entendre vous dire à vous me dire à dieu
existe et il me dire à vis du direct à
mai à vient au mac bien aimé et je lui
dirai je suis là mobya nenê formidable
ça vous êtes un personnage au caire à
mon avis sont embêtés avant d'en
attendre alors les chiffonniers ça je
comprends pourquoi vous avez les
chiffres vous était si populaire auprès
de ramadan je comprends
[Musique]